[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le grand prix de pau aura été cette
année un marché de dupes pour tous les
favoris pilotes et constructeurs y
compris on attendait la victoire du
champion du monde jack brabham au volant
de sa cooper au bout de 20 km jack
brabham et tous les autres races de
l'automobile n'était déjà plus dans la
course s'il avait suivi ce conseil
leur voiture aurait peut-être tenu
jusqu'au bout les pilotes ne sont pas
très en forme et les voitures pas tout à
fait au point g qui fait un tête à queue
en sait quelque chose
peut-être un signe en numéro 4 victime
d'une cascade d'incidents il n'ira pas
loin
pas plus le belge sein de biens numéro
c'est en définitive un jeune écossais de
25 ans tim clark
au volant de sa lotus numéro 6 qui
remporte le grand prix de pau à plus de
102 de moyenne lorsque débute le match
france espagne à madrid devant 80000
spectateurs on se demande si les joueurs
français maillot foncé culotte blanche
ne court pas à la catastrophe
les espagnols sont en effet archi favori
de la rencontre dès les premières
minutes de jeu les français ne font pas
tellement mauvaise figure la catastrophe
ce n'est pas pour ses prouesses
les espagnols sont lents mal inspiré
hormis trento numéro 11 qui s'aiment de
temps à autre le désarroi dans la
défense française
pas de chance l'équipe de france a
besoin d'une demi heure de jeu copains
et hors de combat contre l'espagne à
proximité des bus belle balle de cuba
l'a bien reprise de la tête par santana
1 0 pour l'espagne c'est très flatteur
pour les espagnols pas très convaincant
et très honorable somme toute pour les
français très courageux dans l'ensemble
seulement voilà le courage n'est pas
suffisant pour marquer des buts des
occasions les français en ont en
deuxième mi-temps surtout ils ne savent
pas en tirer partie en revanche les
espagnols dominent et parfois
techniquement sont beaucoup plus
réalistes comme benneteau qui marque un
second but pour l'espagne qui va la
france par 2 à 0
et
malgré les sourires compte échanger à
washington le président kennedy et
monsieur gromyko au cours d'une entrevue
qui a fait quelques bruits l'inquiétude
suscitée par la sphère laotienne reste
au premier plan des soucis
internationaux le prince sovanna phum à
qui s'est entretenu à paris avec
monsieur michel debré et les
responsables français
parviendra-t-il à faire triompher sa
thèse chef du gouvernement renversé par
le général phung me il espère convaincre
le monde de la nécessité d'une politique
de neutralité au laos
[Musique]
le pâle visage de lister leurs sortant
de sa clinique londonienne aux côtés de
son mari eddie fisher aura été plus apte
que le lointain la hausse a passionné
les foules
l' enthousiasme de ses admirateurs de
londres en est le témoignage
le salut de new york ne le fut pas moins
son arrivée et des choeurs innombrables
dans le vaste monde
or ont repris leur rythme normal à la
nouvelle que la belle vedette par ai
passé quatre mois de convalescence en
californie
la gloire et plus rebelles sans doute
pour les inventeurs quand même ils
auraient dut génie
quel touriste aurait l'idée en passant à
liège en belgique de rendre visite à
l'horloger louis zimmer qui donnait
pourtant voici 30 ans à la cité flamande
son plus beau fleuron latour zimmer qui
renferme une étonnante horloge
astronomique presque adrien dit qu'avec
l'heure de greenwich leur démarrer la
saison le jour le mois leur la semaine
le cycle solaire le signe du zodiaque
l'équation du temps le cycle lunaire et
les phases de la lune
à midi des personnages apparaissent à
une fenêtre
les trois premiers roi de belgique ne
faut-il pas admirer l'esprit qui a
engendré un pareil mécanisme lequel
anime aussi un planétarium et trois
panneaux entier de cadran astronomiques
sans oublier le personnage qui en ce
faisant nous apprend les changements de
poids qui nous attend sur les autres
planètes
[Musique]
l'europe tentent de s'unir à strasbourg
17 nations continue la discussion mais
jusqu'ici on a pu créer que deux europe
celle des 7 et celle des six l'europe
des six a pris corps avec le traité de
rome depuis on s'efforce de compléter
cet édifice qui a propagé au graphique
un bloc continental compact inscrits
dans la géographie la tentation à
l'unité mais aussi dans l'économie
l'europe des six groupes et dans le
marché commun dispose en effet de
possibilités agricole variés et
complémentaires
ouais
elle dispose aussi d'un potentiel
industriel considérable puisqu'il est
trois fois supérieur à celui de l'autre
europe celle des cèpes
s'y ajoutent enfin un facteur historique
le souvenir de l' empire de charlemagne
[Musique]
les barrières douanières et les poteaux
frontières apparaissent dans ces
conditions comme des obstacles assez
mince à la réalisation d'une unité
économique voire d'une unité politique
qui n'est pas sans avoir déjà des
partisans résolus
[Musique]
tout autre nom se présente les sept
nations dispersés sur la carte en
majorité maritime et dont l'économie
repose essentiellement sur les échanges
au nord comme au sud ces pays ont une
solide tradition de commerçants au long
cours peuple de marins dont l'histoire
fourmille de découvrir de terres
lointaines les vasco de gama et de
christophe colomb
ses caractéristiques ses capitales sont
des ports comme lisbonne comme londres
comme stockholm
c'est aussi le cas d'oslo et de
copenhague
[Musique]
mais la suisse direz vous c'est que son
économie fait aussi d'échanger de
spéculation s'assimile parfaitement à
celle des nations maritimes
mais l'autriche son cas est particulier
le traité de paix en a fait un pays
auquel une association européenne aussi
précise que celle des six est interdite
les réalités font que l'europe des six
est une tentation pour l'europe entière
la grèce vient d'y faire son entrée
malgré les sollicitations du groupe des
sept conduit par l'angleterre
l'angleterre n'est elle même pas
insensible à l'après des 6 et multiplie
ses sourires au point qu'on a pu dire
qu'elles rôdent autour du marché commun
[Musique]
et l'on comprend très bien cette
tentation pour des peuples de marchin
lorsqu'on imagine que les six forme d'un
marché de 180 millions de clients et
c'est peut-être pourquoi un jour
l'europe des six et l'europe 17
s'uniront pour faire l'europe tout court
[Musique]
c'est vers une turquie inconnu que
conduit ce pont romain jeter voici vingt
siècles sur un affluent du hot flat
infiniment rares en effet sont ceux qui
comme jean jacques fleury et pierre
birot les auteurs de ces images ont
voulu atteindre au sommet de la montagne
de nems road derniers contreforts du
taurus le tumulus antiochus au pied de
l'énorme amas de cailloutis
d'impressionnants figure de pierre
démantelé par le temps veille sur le
tombeau d'un caucus premier roi de comme
à gênes prince peu connu qui régnait au
1er siècle avant jésus-christ sur l'un
des pays les plus ignorés aujourd'hui
des tremblements de terre successifs ont
précipité au sol c'était de dieu dont
les hautes silhouettes sculptées dans le
rock domine l entrée du tombeau
souterrain de leurs huit mètres de
hauteur
seul debout aujourd'hui la déesse de la
vie et de la fécondité continue intacte
cette veille deux fois millénaire
[Musique]
personne n'est venu au rendez-vous
déviant le fln s'est refusé à s'y
présenter
les forces de police ont pu multiplier
les patrouilles sans dissimuler pour
cela le vide à névian quand deuil de
souvenirs de son père assassiné
[Musique]
les bocages de l'hôtel du parc reste un
mystère et l'hôtel lui-même et sans voix
evian est aujourd'hui le nom d'un rendez
vous manqué et c'est dans ce climat que
le général de gaulle a voulu exprimer sa
pensée devant 600 journalistes venus du
monde entier
dans le monde actuel et à l'époque où
nous sommes
la france n'a aucun intérêt à maintenir
sous sa loi et sous sa dépendance une
algérie qui choisit un autre destin et
la france n'aurait pas intérêt à porter
à bout de bras
l'existence des populations dans une
algérie qui serait devenue maîtresse
d'elle-même et qu'ils n'offriraient rien
en échange
est ce qu'elles auraient à demander
alors on dit mais ces territoires dans
la france se retirerait y tomberont
aussi tôt dans la misère le chaos
en attendant le communisme c'est en
effet sans doute ce qui leur arrivera
mais alors nous n'aurions plus aucun
devoir à leur égard sinon de les
plaindre
pour le moment la france continue à
ramener l'ordre public à accomplir son
oeuvre de progrès à aider l'algérie à
devenir algérienne dans sa structure
après quoi si ce n'est pas en vain le
coeur et la raison de la france la
porteront sans nul doute vers l'est et
vers l'amitié
[Musique]
aux accents de l'hymne de sénégalais
dakar a fêté avec solennité le premier
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la
république du sénégal aux côtés de
léopold senghor président de la
république
les délégués de 72 nations assistaient à
cette manifestation qui constatait la
maturité et la cohésion de la jeune
nation
le chef du gouvernement les chefs d
etats africains d'expression française
monsieur andré malraux représentant la
france assistaient au défilé qui
clôturait ces journées historiques et où
s'unissent et toutes les forces vives du
pays l'armée
les organisations ouvrières et la
jeunesse
à cette occasion dans un discours d'une
belle élévation le président senghor a
convié le sénégal à la construction de
cette civilisation universelle qui
naîtra de toutes les civilisations
particulière
[Musique]
le sénégal entier à participer à ces
réjouissances venus des provinces
éloignées des groupes ont donné le
spectacle de leurs danses ancestrales un
sénégal aux multiples aspects mais à la
fois enthousiaste et unis c'est aussi
l'indépendance qu'à célébrer la foule de
dar es salaam capitale du tanganyka mais
une indépendance qui ne sera effectif
qu'à la fin de cette année l'atmosphère
toute britannique de la garden party qui
a marqué en haut lieu l'annnonce de
l'événement a contrasté avec
l'exubérance des réactions populaires
affaire de ce type
quant à monsieur julius nyéréré premier
ministre de ce qui était le plus grand
territoire de l'afrique britannique
il a pu dire ce jour est un jour de
triomphe pour le tanganyika
mais ce n'est un triomphe contre
personne
[Musique]
oisiveté mauvaise conseillère faute de
buts plus précis à l'heure des loisirs
elle conduit trop facilement autour
d'une table de café ainsi une certaine
jeunesse sans s'en rendre compte
s'habituer à faire bon ménage avec
l'alcool dont on ne dira jamais assez
qu'il est un fléau national
c'est pourquoi il faut applaudir à des
initiatives telles que celle qui a
abouti à la création à vincennes de la
maison des jeunes et de la culture
ouverte aux jeunes de tous les horizons
qu'ils sortent du collège ou de
l'atelier elle leur offre à travers les
divers clubs de multiples moyens de
meubler leurs loisirs
[Musique]
la maison des jeunes à son restaurant
elle a aussi son bar et garçons et
filles prouve qu'il n'est nullement
nécessaire de s'alcooliser ou de rouler
à 200 à l'heure pour satisfaire à sa
petite fureur de vie il existe
heureusement d'autres chemins pour aller
au devant de la vie
[Musique]
un avion qui a atterri trop vite sur une
piste c'est la catastrophe non un oeil
électronique qui a repéré l'avion
déclenche automatiquement une barrière
d'art pour attraper un set en plein vol
il n'existe rien de mieux que le filet à
papillons de grand papa les techniciens
français de l'armée de l'air le savent
bien ils sont astucieux et c'est pour
cela qu'ils se sont inspirés de cette
méthode pour rattraper au vol les avions
en perdition sur une piste à
l'atterrissage ou à l'école
et voilà le filet est en nylon comme une
paire de bas il a cependant un avantage
sur les bas c'est meine fils jamais de
nombreux pays étrangers s'intéressent à
ce système
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par exemple de l'astuce des techniciens
français le parachutisme est un sport
passionnant cependant il n'est pas à la
portée de toutes les bourses
un ingénieur français monsieur le moigne
a trouvé un moyen pour faire du
parachutisme un sport pas cher plus
besoin d'avion ni de torah par htc le
moniteur chef papasoff qui expérimente
le nouveau procédé très simple de
l'ingénieur le moigne le parachute est
tirée par un camion après quelques
mètres de course toujours tirée par le
camion le parachutiste célèbre
automatiquement dans le ciel à une
centaine de mètres du sol
il retombe ensuite tout naturellement
exactement comme s'il avait pris son
élan d'une tour à parachute
et ce n'est pas plus dense
[Musique]
faut croire que les champions cyclistes
n'ont pas peur du diable puisqu'ils sont
quelque 150 au départ de la course paris
roubaix qui passent traditionnellement
par itil par l'enfer du nord
nous n'en sommes pas encore là les
mauvaises intentions des organisateurs
sont réservés pour la fin du parcours
[Musique]
malgré quelques escarmouches durant la
première partie de l'épreuve à amiens le
peloton passe très groupée les routes
sont encore bonnes
et puis c'est tellement plus agréable de
se ravitailler en com pas la peine de
courir chacun aura sa musette
quelques-uns auront même une bûche pour
décès on ne pas trop s'ennuyer
on continue de rouler deux concerts
et puis 20 km de l'arrivée huit hommes
s'échappent par mieux le belge rik van
looy qui règlent tout le monde au sprint
au vélodrome de roubaix
rien de tel pour oublier d'en faire que
le baiser d'un ange
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le château du ministère la maison du
crime
[Musique]
nous sommes chez fantômas ou plutôt chez
le père de fantômas marcel allain qui
avec souvestre voici cinquante ans
écrivit cette série extraordinaire de
lait pouvant en chambre fantôme ainsi
une vie de quarante quatre volumes 44
volume au titre hallucinant aux épisodes
insensé qui cinquante ans après vont
reprendre vie dans une nouvelle édition
[Musique]
quarante quatre volumes bourré de crime
et semer de guillotine qui se rient du
quotidien dafu les conformismes et vont
jusqu'à faire du dandy assassin un
véritable mythe est ce à cause de ces
étranges vertus que fantômas est resté
dans l'esprit des foules et qu'à la
silhouette du lecteur de 1911
correspondent celle du blues au plus ou
moins coloré de l'anneau notre
génération comme celle qui l'attend
c'est reste peut-être anxieuse devoir
passer sur les toits de paris
cette silhouette de mondains et feast of
eli qu être à notre époque pour un tas
de reuver de sensations fortes
cette réincarnation du diable c'est la
question que nous avons posée à marcel
alin rien a tellement changé et ses
fantômes à ce qui vous le dit
on s'est beaucoup passionné temps à
colombes qu'à marseille pour les demi
finales de la coupe de france de
football à colombes ce sont les
bordelais maillot à chevrons et les
sedanais qui s'efforce de gagner le
droit de participer à la finale sedan
prend une option en marquant le premier
but par son avant-centre mouchel options
de courte durée puisqu'une minute à
peine s'est écoulée lorsque les
bordelais égalise tout est remise en
question
sedan cependant reprend l'avantagé en
deuxième mi temps
le sort de la partie par est réglé et
bien non les bordeaux n'est décidément
très en verve cette année en coupe de
france arrachent le match nul à
marseille scénario presque identique
c'est l'équipe de première division
nîmes maillot foncé qui marque le
premier but devant montpellier
[Applaudissements]
les nîmois obtiennent un second but
surprise en deuxième mi temps
on croit alors que les joueurs de
montpellier vont baisser les bras pas du
tout mais les montpelliérains ne peuvent
que réduire le score à 2-1
voici revenu le temps où les beaux jours
réveil le démon de laventure qui
sommeille dans le coeur de chaque
citadin le temps des explorateurs comme
des paysans du dimanche
[Musique]
et que de découvertes ne peut faire un
oeil neuf à travers de vraies lunettes
de soleil au hasard des secrets et des
travaux d'une ferme la moindre scène de
la vie quotidienne il vient un tableau
idyllique
dès qu'on la considère à travers des
verts réellement absorbant et sans doute
en s'attachant à protéger la vue du
soleil sans départ et un joli visage
les opticiens français n'avait il pas
songé que leur création pourrait être
autant de moyens de transfigurer les
petites servitudes de la vie campagnarde
[Musique]
il n'en faut pas douter le secours de la
lunetterie est aujourd'hui aussi
nécessaire aux aventuriers du week end
que le masque respiratoire au découvreur
de l'espace le monde est tellement plus
gentils comme ça
[Musique]
le gaz d'éclairage et sa production
locale appartiennent au passé
depuis 47 375 petites usines ont disparu
aujourd'hui le dispatching central de
paris règne sur un réseau de
canalisations qui se développe chaque
jour une telle transformation de
l'économie gazière a été rendue possible
par la création de centrales géantes
comme celle d'alfortville qui sont les
coeurs mécanique d'un immense système
circulatoire
ici le robot est roi des détecteurs
automatiques surveille les tapis
roulants
qu'ils arrêtent au passage de corps
étrangers indésirables
chargement des fours défournement du coq
sont pratiquement réalisé sans aucune
intervention humaine sinon de
surveillance
le gaz produit est absorbé par un monde
surréaliste de conduite auquel viennent
se mêler les canalisations du gaz
naturel de lacs et du gaz fabriqué en
lorraine dosé mélanger le gaz entre
alors dans les compresseurs dont
l'ensemble constitue une réalisation
sans égal en europe
l'homme n'intervient qu'au niveau des
boutons images des temps nouveaux le gaz
de france est placé à la pointe du
progrès
[Musique]
c'est l'instinct de suspense sur
l'aérodrome de moscou des milliers de
regards se sont concentrés sur l'homme
en uniforme qui descend d'avion
youri alexeïevitch gagarine le président
coach of avait voulu être le premier à
le serrer dans ses bras il le fit dans
l' enthousiasme
[Applaudissements]
huile oury gagarine en grâce à un père
et une mère dont on imagine l'émotion
[Applaudissements]
le jour j'ai comme gagarine avait
commencé pour moscou une ovation
ininterrompue a conduit l'homme de
l'espace jusqu'à la place rouge et à la
tribune du mausolée de lénine la foule
qu'on a évalué à plus d'un million de
personnes a pu acclamer à loisir l'homme
qui peut le premier se vanter d'avoir vu
de ses yeux la terre ronde comme une
boule et d'avoir vécu la plus
extraordinaire aventure du siècle
s'avère bien visible le général de
gaulle l'a consacré au sud-ouest et
l'accueil de périgueux où le chef de
l'état s'est recueilli devant le
cénotaphe de la résistance fut à l'image
de celui de chacune des villes
traversées à l'image de celui de
bordeaux où l'a cueilli le maire
monsieur chaban delmas dans chaque ville
le général de gaulle avait choisi
d'évoquer l'algérie est la capitale du
sud ouest l'a entendu réaffirmé le
double but de la france
la paix et l'association à tous les
algériens y compris d'abord bien sûr
ceux qui jusqu'à présent refusé de
prendre les mains que nous leur tendons
l'algérie nouvelle si elle le veut fera
son tueur chemin aux côtés la france
nouvelle
dans sa cage de verre à l'épreuve des
balles
iceman une silhouette banal en face
trois juges
rien de spectaculaire nous sommes
cependant peut-être devant le plus
énorme et le plus étrange procès de
l'histoire car sous les phrases sans
relief de l'acte d'accusation
ce sont 5 millions de juifs qui parle
cinq millions de morts
car iceman fut dans ce qui fut appelé
l'ordre nazi
celui qui eut pour mission d'organiser
la solution finale du problème juif et
l'on sait ce que l'on doit entendre par
là où contes d'hoffmann le boycottage
sociale l'arrestation arbitraire la
suppression des droits civiques de ce
qu'ils étaient juifs bagatelle de la
porte mais la porte s'ouvrait sur quoi
elle ouvrait sur la rafle le temps de
concentration il reste sept iceman
l'inventeur de l'étoile jaune c'est
teichmann le créateur du camp de drancy
qui reste dans la mémoire des français
c'est ashman le créateur du travail
obligatoire pour ces foules qui n'avait
à attendre ni secours ni pitié le
travail obligatoire et tout ce que
pouvait dissimuler ce vocable innocent
c'est un chemin de l'organisateur
davidts auschwitz qui est signée iceman
aux frites qui fut à proprement parler
le camp où l'on entrait par la porte
mais d'où l'on sortait par la cheminée
5 millions de juifs passèrent par cet
enclos sinistre ou le gaz cyclone permis
de donner à la mort la productivité
industrielle indispensable à la solution
finale du problème juif
iceman aussi la création des fours
crématoires qui achevait l'oeuvre du gaz
tic l' iceman l'organisateur sans défaut
cette idée de récupération totale qui
des cheveux des cadavres alors des
dentiers des chaussures aux vêtements
transforma le tortionnaire en
chiffonniers et jusqu'au locke et
jusqu'aux appareils de prothèses et cela
c'est peut-être au delà de l'horreur
[Musique]
au compte- deichmann encore la
séparation des familles cette misère et
cette abjection ou tombent l'homme dans
la promiscuité des camps
[Musique]
à lui aussi la honte des expériences
scientifiques sur des cobayes humains
telles celles qui réunit une centaine de
jumeaux et nous ne faisons que citer les
chefs d'accusation
[Musique]
iceman toujours l'abomination dernière
d'avoir condamné même des enfants à la
claustration à la famine à la maladie à
la folie et à la mort iceman écoute et
répond le plus étrange est même qu'il
écoute et qu'il réponde
pensez-y qu'est ce qu'il y a au fond de
cet homme que peut-on faire d'un iceman
[Musique]
avec la même solennité qui avait entouré
ses funérailles voici 26 ans lyautey
aura quitté cette terre marocaine qu'il
avait tenté mais et à laquelle il avait
consacré la plus belle part de sa
volonté et de son esprit en présence
d'une foule dans laquelle se mêlaient
les visages française et marocains le
cercueil passant des mains de l'armée
marocaine aux mains des marins français
a été déposée pour son dernier voyage
sur la plage arrière du colbert le plus
beau bâtiment de la flotte française
yoplait
c'est un nom et un visage le nom et le
visage de l'homme qui sut donner un
avenir moderne à un pays resté au rythme
du moyen-âge ces images de 1912 retrace
quelques instants de l'action grandiose
qui fit d'une terre dit viser un royaume
pacifié et d'une nature hostile le plus
beau domaine de l'afrique du nord
pacificateur lyautey nous à pâques des
armes en portant au sultanat le jeune
mohamed ben youssef qui devait devenir
le roi mohamed 5
il assura le pouvoir central jusqu'à
leur discuter bâtisseurs d'empiré
politique il fut en même temps le
constructeur matériel d'un pays
la pioche et la truelle furent ses
outils préférés
mais cette fièvre de constructeurs et
d'ouvreur de route ne lui fit jamais
perdre de vue la personnalité du pays
qu'il transformait il sut conserver les
usages les traditions les rides
profondes de ce maroc auquel ils
enlevaient les bandelettes qui leur
tenait en marge des grands routes
modernes il le fait si bien qu il pu
dans un temps de troubles et sur un
territoire non pas s'y fier entrez dans
fais presque sans escorte au milieu des
pèlerins et se mêler au fait qui
accompagne chaque année le pèlerinage de
moulay idriss
[Musique]
créateur au vu large il eu l'audace
d'organiser deux ans après la soumission
de la ville
la foire de fès qui devait par la suite
devenir l'une des manifestations
économiques les plus importantes du
maroc et joindre même assez aux soucis
d'avenir
un grain de fantaisie et de souris
[Musique]
c'est ce lyautey le bâtisseur d'empiré
comme on le nomma qui revient en france
les circonstances ne permettent pas
toujours aux hommes de décider à jamais
ni de leur destin ni de leur tombeau
mais lyautey restera toujours présent au
maroc et il n'y a pour le savoir qu'à
regarder ce qu'il a fait d'un coin de
côte où il n'y avait rien casablanca
et
au milieu d'un parterre d'amis du cinéma
pierre blanchard qu'entourée la petite
fille de georges méliès et de nombreuses
personnalités a célébré à la mairie de
montreuil le centenaire de la naissance
de l'homme qui fut le créateur du film
romancée c'est à montreuil en effet que
méliès construisit les premiers studios
de cinéma à cette place qu'occupe
aujourd'hui une scierie c'est là que de
1896 à 1922 fut retournée près de 4000
films parmi lesquels ce voyage dans la
lune qui fit courir en 1902 les foules
de l'époque les super productions
d'aujourd'hui sont loin de ses débuts
mais elles ne font que développer ce qui
était en puissance dans ses productions
qu'on regarde comme enfantine à méliès
revient la gloire d'avoir le premier
déceler toutes les possibilités du
septième art d'avoir inventé le récit
cinématographique
la mise en scène le trucage le décor il
n'en profita pas et mourut peau saluons
le centenaire de georges méliès
ce fut un grand monsieur
[Musique]
l'invasion de cuba par les anti
castristes s'est soldée par un échec
un raid aérien sur la havane avait
marqué le début des opérations
fidel castro avait en pleurant les
victimes charger les états unis de la
responsabilité de la fai
à miami un bombardier cubain atteint par
la dc avait disposé et son équipage
disait s'être rebellé contre castro
l'attaquent puis la défaite des
anticastristes rontes eu un
retentissement considérable
les cubains exilés à miami ont manifesté
contre le régime de fidel castro à
moscou a eu lieu une manifestation
monstre appuyant les accusations de
castro contre les états unis
ces accusations qu'a réagi le président
kennedy en exprimant que l'amérique ne
tolérerait pas indéfiniment une menace
communiste à 150 km de ses côtes avant
de vivre les heures dramatiques que l'on
sait la france avait reçu le sénégal de
l'elysée où le président senghor était
l'hôte du général de gaulle au château
de champs où le général de gaulle était
l'hôte du président senghor trois
journées ont permis de constater la
réalité d'une amitié née voici trois
siècles est perpétuée par delà
l'indépendance proclamée il ya un an
[Musique]
et
au terme de cette visite une soirée de
gala devait être donnée à la
comédie-française en l'honneur du
président de la république sénégal est
[Musique]
ayant deux soirées ou bien des visages
n'était pas inconnu à l'ancien membre du
gouvernement français que fut monsieur
léopold sédar senghor
[Musique]
le calme d'alger était trompeur
soudainement alger a basculé dans un
drame qui agite aujourd'hui la france et
au delà des frontières le nom d' attaché
à la solution du problème algérien mise
en route par le général de gaulle les
français ont soudain découvert le
gouffre risquait de s'enliser le pays
lorsqu à l'elysée à la sortie d'un
conseil des ministres convoqué d'urgence
la nouvelle fut annoncée et que le
ministre de l'information monsieur louis
terrenoire déclara aux journalistes là
était décidé de déférer à la justice
militaire
les généraux challe salle en jouant et
zeller ainsi que le colonel godard à ce
moment le général salins en espagne
combiner son départ pour alger le
pouvoir était tombé aux mains de quatre
généraux qui s'était saisie d'alger puis
dorrans enfin de constantine le délégué
général monsieur jean morin étaient
prisonniers des rebelles ainsi que le
général gambienne commandante en chef
monsieur louis joxe ministre de
l'algérie après une mission de 24 heures
revenait à l'elysée faire son rapport et
les français au soir du 23 avril
entendait à la radio la voix du général
de gaulle au nord de la france j'en dors
que tous les moyens jeudi tous mes
moyens soit employé partout pour barrer
la route à ces hommes là en attendant de
les réduire
j'ai interdit à tout français est
d'abord à tout soldat d'exécuter aucun
de leurs jambes
françaises français voyez où risque
d'aller la france par rapport à ce
qu'elle était en train de re de vie
françaises français ayant noir
pour compléter leur chance les rebelles
tenterait-il un raid sur paris dans la
nuit une dramatique partie se déroulait
où le sort de la nation était en jeu des
chars prenez position aux points
stratégiques et le peuple de paris était
appelé à tenir son rôle dans ce drame
inattendu c'est par milliers qu'ont pu
compter les engagements réclamés pour
secondes et les forces de l'ordre
le gouvernement avait pris ces mesures
de sauvegarde est assurée la sécurité
nationale
le jour se leva sur une floraison de
titres dramatique
[Musique]
vide sur les aérodromes tout trafic
était suspendu
il devait reprendre partiellement
piste qui demeure évident prête à être
encombré de camions pour empêcher tout
atterrissage
à la nuit de fièvre avait succédé une
journée de fiers une grève d'une heure
marquée la décision des centrales
syndicales d'aidé dans son oeuvre le
chef de l'état et 7h d'inaction fut le
signe le plus évident de l'accord
national
pendant une heure d'un consentement
général tout s'arrêta ce référendum
d'année les autres la france tout
entière en ces heures lourdes a marqué
qu'elle était d'accord avec son chef
[Musique]
une